good evening everyone and welcome to
this evening's northwest area planning
committee and this is the 2nd of
february 2022.
my name is councillor maddie thompson
i'm the chairman of the committee before
we commence the business of the meeting
there are a few housekeeping rules to
run through
members we're now working with the set
up for the meeting as agreed at council
on the second of september most aspects
are back to the pre-code but normal
however some people will choose to wear
a mask or take other measures and i
would ask you to respect that please
we are streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and buying by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consent to being recorded
when invited to speak please turn on
your microphone and speak clearly
referencing a page or paragraph number
when referring to the agenda papers
please keep your contributions as clear
and concise as possible and ensure your
microphones remain off when not speaking
as this is important for the live
streaming to be heard clearly
please be aware of the differing levels
of floor and the chamber and the steps
between them i'm not expecting a fire
drill so if the alarm sounds we need to
leave by this door and assembling the
car park at the front of the building
finally can i draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda papers regarding
i've just said this different levels of
flooring
okay members may i draw your attention
to the members update with further
information on gen item five on the
agenda
uh right mr bultitude have we got
apologies for absence
right uh item number three is the
minutes of the last meeting can i take
those as read members
councillor morris in attendance please
chair
um yeah okay
if you could knock that in the minutes
thank you
uh where was i right remembers anything
any items of accuracy to raise
can we agree those buyers send everybody
happy nobody not happy okay thank you
uh so the next thing is declarations of
interest i have to read this bit i'm
afraid to disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard to paragraphs six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members and members are reminded they're
also required to disclose any such
interests as soon as they become aware
should the need arise through the
meeting
councillor durham
thank you chairman i have a nominatory
interest that's a member of the county
council who a statutory consultees thank
you thank you
don't see anyone else so we're moving on
to our first planning item
gender item five
this is land north of poplar grove chase
great totem
the presenting officer is
mrs herner and
we do have
someone to speak the member of the
public actually the agent to speak
following the presentation so if we can
have that please
thank you chairman so this application
seeks outline permission for one
three-bedroom detached dwelling and it's
with all matters reserved
so here you can see the location plan so
to the east of the site and there is
actually an extent outline permission
for three detached dwellings and this is
the existing access to the site taken
and from
the highway here and and through the
buildings within the site
this is the indicative block plan and
it's important to note that layouts and
access are reserved matters and but
given that the access the existing
access is not fully included within the
red line boundary and having regard to
the size and shape of the application
site it's considered that it's unlikely
that there would be much scope to alter
the layout of the development
significantly in comparison to what is
shown here
the blue line also shows a land that's
within the applicant's ownership
and the
site was previously subject to
two dismissed appeals for um larger
dwellings within that location
here that we have the indicative
proposed elevations
this indicative proposed ground floor
plan
and first floor plan
so here are some site photos the um top
left photo is where the um
likely access would be so it would
require some clearing of
the scrub and trees that you can see
there and then we have the application
site and its existing um stable
outbuilding
the existing residential properties and
that would have the largest views of the
application site are shown in the bottom
left and then we also have the site
looking east where you can also see um
the approved scheme that would be behind
the hedgerow
that's actually separated from the site
by um
a ditch and a slight a small bit of
intervening land
uh we have some more photographs of the
um surrounding field and the existing
access
and there's the intervening um land that
i was talking about here so that's not
within the application site or within
the neighbouring site that benefits from
the outline permission
this is where the um driveway would be
through to the proposed dwelling
the existing access off of the road and
then again and this is the access
towards the existing highway
the construction of the three-bedroom
dwelling on the site and its associated
paraphernalia is considered to represent
an unwelcome visual intrusion into the
site and would represent an un well
unacceptable form of backland
development as it's got no active
frontage with the existing build form
and and also the
development would urbanize this site to
quite significant degree
uh it's also discussed in the members
update that it's noted there's an
existing outbuilding on the site but
it's of a much smaller scale in both
than a dwelling it doesn't come with the
associated paraphernalia and is more
agricultural in appearance and more in
keeping with the semi-rural character of
the site and
there's also a barn to the north of the
um
application site but again this is of a
different character than a dwelling
and there's
likewise the existing outline permission
for the free dwellings to the east there
within the existing
pattern of development within the
settlement um and
again and not of the
same character as the application site
it's noted there are some public
benefits to the scheme such as providing
a three bedroom to touch dwelling sorry
just free benjamin dwelling which would
contribute to our housing need but the
social and economic benefits are not
considered to overcome the um
environmental harm that's been
identified on the character appearance
of the site therefore it's recommended
for refusal thank you chairman
thank you very much uh right we have a
member of the public who's attending via
teams that's mrs melanie bingham watts
if we could get mrs bingham what's
online please
good evening good evening um you have
two minutes which will start the clock
when you begin so i trust you're
comfortable and please begin when you're
ready
thank you the officer does indeed find
positives for his application the site
the design is of traditional
scale sorry style and form and
commensurate to the built design in the
area the site is sustainable in terms of
access to public services and transport
and there are no objections on the
amount of parking provision the access
track would not be over intensified by
the news
adequate immunity space has been
provided there is no objection on
ecology grounds and around security
payments have been secured
the self-built register demonstrates
over six years 52 houses and sites have
been given permission and the council
has met his need to clarify there is no
capping of these numbers that is 52
additional houses with a five-year
supply
it is put forward that the proposal
would give significant harm in character
and appearance to the era in reform of
backline development
i argue that the permission of the three
dwellings that cited immediately to the
east are of a significant material
consideration
the proposed development would follow
the development pattern in a forthcoming
reserve matters application
the report notes there will be bolton
effect
careful design taking into consideration
the appearance of the three permitted
houses and the proposed development has
the potential to overcome any disparity
and create a cohesive appearance
careful landscaping and the piping of
the ditch
would prevent a disconnection between
the three permitted houses and the
proposed self-build dwelling
the permission of the three houses
constitutes back a form of backline
development itself a precedent has been
set on site already this proposal would
follow that built form
part two of the backline development the
officer finds that there'll be no
unacceptable material impact on living
conditions and amenity on nearby
properties
there'll be no unacceptable loss of land
of its social economic historic
environmental significance the ecology
report establishes the cycles of limited
scale and diversity
there are no heritage features or
ecology
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm going to stop
you there okay i am always very strict
but
i think you've got most of your message
across haven't you um right members i'm
going to open the discussion now and
invite you to put any questions or make
any comments you wish to um
and out of that i hope we're going to
get a proposal and we can vote on that
when we have the specifics uh i actually
spotted council miss white first so
thank you i'll come to everyone
okay and thank you chairman um i've got
a couple of questions and one is are the
applicants myself build register
um because i think the agent mentioned
it um because i know as a member i
raised an investigation into the
self-build register because the council
has a duty to keep register up to date
and as far as i'm aware there are a lot
of sites that are included on the
register that weren't actually
self-built because they have to have a
self-building a title and there's a box
that you tick on the application form
um and for me that's that's a lot of
what i've never actually heard back from
officers um but for me there's a lot of
weight that should be attached to that
because they although it's not a
guarantee you'll get planning permission
um do you know if they cancelled off the
many sites anywhere else for self-build
i think it i'm not aware that this
particular applicant's been offered any
other sites the site is itself sorry
they are on the self build register and
but we've found that we've um allocated
the
more than what was is required on the
self-built register for the um last
period
yeah but if i might come back i have
raised this as a member on a couple of
occasions and i think it's gone to ons
that a lot of the applications they're
supposed to be self-built only
and it's not the register is not meant
to include i'm not having a go it's not
meant to include agricultural buildings
it's not meant to build anything else
and it's not meant to include ones which
happen to be self-built it's meant to be
purely for
self-build applications so for me i
think that that weighs in its favor
um
and it is
i'm quite right in thinking it is
adjacent to these houses and we've just
been looking at google earth
and it appears to be surrounded by
houses on all sides so yeah so is that
right is it in the middle of all the
houses as it looks like it is
can we go back to that picture
i think that might be helpful which
would be the plan
two
sides
that have now got permission are they to
the right-hand side of the application
site
yes they're within this site here but
this parcel of small parcel of land here
isn't included within either application
site
uh that would just be age or something
but no awesomeness thank you very much
thank you
thank you
i just think the other thing to point
out that there is a defined development
boundary
um that's something which has been noted
by
the inspector on the previous decisions
and it's also mentioned within the
offices
uh report it's also been highlighted
within the appeal decisions the
important nature of
this open area here particularly because
of the development of the garden suburb
and the
element of the of the countryside which
you know is then highlighted and valued
as a result of that
that was all that was part of the reason
for the refusal of the previous schemes
notwithstanding their size as well and
this is also part of our consideration
to the unacceptability of
this development in encroaching into
that space
so it's not from our point of view just
the fact that we have development
nearby development nearby always nearby
somewhere there's always going to be
some junction at which you'll have the
development boundary and the countryside
or open space
it's it's important here particularly
because of the development which is
taking place around and this just
provides that further relief
uh because of the development within the
area and that's to be taken into
consideration
otherwise from our point of view you
will have this creep development the
arguments that could be made um against
the obvious refusal is that okay it's at
the back there's development around
nearby
sort of what's the harm another person
comes along then it's going to be become
much more difficult to then
resist that position
thank you chairman thank you
if i might come back is there any way of
putting a condition on that would
protect the rest of the field from
development is there a way of doing that
no there isn't okay well i'm going to
look at the actual quality planners here
but i believe not
thank you uh i actually have councillor
keys next and councillor durham oh
okay if you'd like to round up that's
absolutely fine
thank you i wonder uh mrs hernan have
you got the um
the uh
scheme
that was refused on appeal have you got
the slide for that we can just see that
so that occupied that pretty much that
whole field
and then now go back to
the application here
so we've gone from one extreme to
another haven't we
now
i don't know i mean
i don't think i just fell from the apple
tree now to me
and i know this is not a planning
consideration
but this opens that remainder of that
site for another eight or ten houses
um
which okay would have to be dealt with
in their own right
but i think that
being mr cynical that is the reason for
this application to establish the
precedent and then we will see within a
very short space of time
application for eight or ten
houses on that green
on that uh the rest of that land um but
uh
as i said that's not a reason to um
to refuse this particular application um
i'm just nervous of it chairman
for that reason
thank you anyone else before i come to
arsenal keys
that's the keys like a flawless much
right um
back land development seems to be the
main thing this has turned down for now
if could i have a look at the side
slides please
of the from the site out to colchester
road please
no
no
that's that one there the bottom right
hand side one
where your mouse is now
if you go to the house on the left
in the far side road that house there by
the side of that house which is almost
dead opposite this application
it is called
northland's farm that house where the
the mouse is and behind there you've got
willow barn and you've got
a large bungalow with stables that set a
further back off of the b1022 than
whatever this house if it
that's in the application now
you know it's northlands it's called
northland's house behind it is
northland's farm then there's willow
barn which is a converted barn and then
behind that
is a bungalow with
i don't know five or six stables and one
would have said it's a 1970s build
bungalow and that is definitely set back
further than what this application is
also
on this
as you come out of the site turn left
and head towards great tottenham as you
come directly into great torture south
there was an old bungalow probably about
12 years ago they knocked it down and
built one in the front and one behind so
that's barbara's that's
back landed no the next one up well
is barber's close
yeah where there's three large houses
just inside the village of great
tottenham and then just up further i
don't know the name of it but there's a
cul-de-sac which again
is back land development and there's
three large houses in there of this i
don't know the name of that road it's an
unmarked that's an unknown road then on
the right hand side number 37
and council of dharma probably remember
this pony and gould from wiccan bishops
that's where the sun lives there and he
built a house behind on the opposite
side of the road just before you get to
the cafe what we all know of that was in
great tottenham number 37 and obviously
you've got poplar grove next door to it
and if you come out of the site
turn right towards haybridge
and i don't know the name of the house
but there's a cottage on the left-hand
side just past where the crown pub what
we all know was the crown pub and the
lady there
won a house behind it on a pill
about two
might be three years ago it went for a
pill she built one in her garden right
behind he said as you go down the road
on the left-hand side past the ground
it's you you can't miss it it's a nice
little cottage proper
like a christmas postcard cottage one
would say well behind that she built a
house in the garden and she won that for
a pill so i think
to be consistent which i keep getting
told by malden council and great totten
parish council and all the rest of it
i've just named a few here of this
backland development
and i know i called in the application
to start with which was the ones in the
front which we all know as the dairy
they are back land to start with because
there's a house in front of them the
industrial
and i think that's
probably you've got poplar grove next
door on the left-hand side and in the
last
10 years i would imagine there's
at least five houses have been built
down there
okay
thank you
thank you chairman um
and i appreciate council of keys
in history of the area uh but but i
think on the on the
on the
plan of the site if
devon would like to just just bring it
up again
um
you know
this is this is the area we're dealing
with
um
in addition to the application site you
have the defined wider site which is
owned by the by the applicant
i think the photo is quite clearly
showed
you know relatively recent photos
showing vistas from
right around the site that there is no
development within the area now i i can
clearly understand that there will be
development plotted around um each
development is considered on its merits
each development is considered within
its context so i sort of fully
appreciate that but the circumstances of
this site have been considered
um
clearly under this application but
through the previous applications
notwithstanding the fact that there was
a larger development before it's
considering the site in it in its
totality and taken in its whole area and
the potted context that i gave earlier
on which i think is is quite relevant
and also i think um
the issue of precedent is also we can't
make decisions solely on precedent but
we think that this is a consideration
that we should bear in mind here as well
because that's part of the overall
context um
council durham i understand why i'm
saying maybe not planning but alluded to
that in some in you know you know to
some extent it then starts to become
difficult for us when we're considering
the context of the site with further
development coming forward
um the officer in in in her report sets
out clearly that there is development
on the eastern side um while there is
intervening uh an intervening ditch
while while there is hedging so there is
a separation we are quite
aware that there is that development
there
that scheme was approved by members
against officers recommendation
i think that was when i more or less not
long just joined the council
so i
remember i remember it quite clearly um
you know um
and yeah and there are a few others
which have been allowed on appeal within
the vicinity again these are set up
within the report but they're clearly
explained within their particular
context
um for us in making our planning
decisions
it is the wider area we consider we do
have the garden suburb which is not
clearly a million miles away from here
it is also protecting the context within
which that garden suburb
is being developed and that has been
alluded to for this site in previous
decisions so
so it's incumbent upon us to have regard
for that and that is a material
consideration thank you
thank you
that's okay
well i'm going to put a proposal forward
if i can to go against the officer's
recommendation
okay
reasons please address the um
conversions
it's well self-built registered mrs um
who watched just told me councillor
white
um
well it's houses in front of it so i
don't know what we can use on that um
i'll never get any help on this when i
want to go against officers but um i'm
on my own
it's a professional thing yeah
i wanted to turn it down
what they recommend oh i don't know
really really self-real regis adjacent
to houses at the front which was
something
benefit outweighs the harm access is
good access on the b1022 we can use that
i should have thought um
agricultural rural diversification i
suppose we could choose that because
there's old agricultural buildings at
the back you've got to address the
development would be visually
prominent from surrounding problems well
i don't think it would because there's
trees and hedges around there so i don't
think if i might assist i i just think i
mean taking my hat off i've applied for
self-built dwelling um previously
um and and i do think for me that
self-built dwellings they're part of the
government um
reports their their benefit to lots of
funding now because the government wants
to promote a self-built revolution and
they're throwing lots of money at it
and i think that for rural communities
to survive it's very important that we
support the self-built registered and
the applicants and i think the benefit
of allowing a local person to build
their own home in line with government
policy
is a benefit in favor of the application
and outweighs the harm that may be
considered from standalone applications
do
i mean you know obviously it's it's
members decision i mean we clearly
understand and respect that i do find
conflict with a number of
um positions that we regularly put
um to
um committee um in making our
recommendations
for example you know the benefit
outweighs the harm i mean this is a
single dwelling
um
it's it's negligible as to whether there
would be any economic developments
beyond the fact that you know it's going
to be a self-built so how in terms of
its benefits to the community in that
sense
and it being used as an argument to
outweigh you know any harm from the
development is i i think personally a
bit dubious
and
you know it would put us in positions
when we're making that same arguments
against other developments i think that
that clearly goes against it i think in
the report it also sets out regarding
the self register just remind me about
this devon that our requirement has been
met
um i do understand the i understand that
the council has made uh comments
regarding but you know there's no
there's no evidence in front of us in
terms of
what's been said in that respect yeah
but if if i'm sorry to come back i have
raised this because if you read the
legislation it's really clear that you
must not include any other applications
within the self-build approvals
and modern district council i can think
of two that were for agricultural
dwellings one was in cold norton wayback
farm
i can't remember some of the others and
it is really specific there is a tick
box on the application form and i've
raised it's not not right and say i've
grown up in this district virtually all
my life
and i think it's important for our
communities to support these self-build
applications so that we allow the rural
fables families to remain in our
district and i know it's a different
between professional opinions and um
residents but as residents who've grown
up in this area it's important we allow
people to stay and to grow and allow
their families to stay under self-built
right in line with government policy
right
5.5.9.4 to me seems fairly clear
um in which you know in all the base
periods accounts that's granted the same
number of or more suitable development
permissions then there are a number of
entries on part one of the register
across the base period there are 15
individuals on part one
in comparison 52 planning permissions
for all suitable for self build have
been granted
given the above this indicates that the
council has met its legal requirement
i think this is i think
but but i'm just on the line in that
because that's also partly an argument
put forward in terms of support in this
application
and in my view that's flawed and
incorporated into that as part of the
reasons and in my opinion the
authorities position is flawed because i
have concerns over the self build
and mr multitude are you clear what this
proposal actually is
and would you like it summed up i think
that would be a good plan myself
um would
one of you
care to some sum up the proposal in
words that we can
get okay i'll have a go at summing it up
um i i believe that the applicants are
on the self-build register and that
they we need to provide more self-built
plots in line with government policy i
also believe the benefit of this
dwelling will outweigh the harm it's
already got a very good access it's
adjacent to three dwellings that already
have permission
and i don't think it's physically
intrusive because it has houses on two
sides um and it is very close in fact
three sides if you look at the it's got
houses on three sides um and for me as a
member not as a professional for me the
benefit always the harm this isn't just
um a random application it is a
self-build which is specific
okay
um i'm going to get council keys your
second cat one second
second definitely are we clear on that
mr altitude we're all right
okay let's take a vote those in favor of
the proposal to approve
with all the reasons given
okay that's three
and those against
ah that's three as well
so as chairman i'm going to have to pass
which i wouldn't automatically do with
the way i voted but because this leaves
us in status quo without
a building not recommended by officers
i'm going to vote against that proposal
we therefore have to fall back on the
recommendation which is to refuse the
reasons given in the report
can i have a second for that thank you
and
i can see exactly where this is going
those who agree the recommendation
as given in the report one two three
no
this shouldn't be happening this should
not be necessary
so kevin would bring
yes
good thinking
no we're definitely not taking this to
full council that's not necessary and i
will in fact ask for the officer's
recommendation
thank you everyone
no problem and right moving on we've got
gender item
six which is
a tree
front boundary between ah 37 and 39
fifth street
um no members update on this one so if
we can have a presentation please
thank you
this report sees confirmation of a tree
preservation order for a sycamore
located in the front boundary of 37 and
39 fish street in goldhanger
so you can see the location of the tree
in plan from here
here's an aerial view of the tree right
i'm frantically looking on here
some photographs looking north and you
can see the photos were taken in the
winter months but even without any
leaves the tree does still offer a
significant amenity value to the area
we have some closer views
views looking towards the south
some closer views
and this is the base of the tree and
showing some cracks in the
driveways
the council received a notification to
fill the sycamore tree as it lies in the
conservation area and so the works would
require permission however due to the
prominent location and size of the tree
along with the lack of any agricultural
justification for its removal the
unjustified removal of the tree was
considered to materially impact on the
immunity of the area therefore a tempo
assessment was carried out and the tree
scored 15 out of 25
warranty in a tree preservation order a
tree preservation order was then served
on the 14th of september
as an unresolved letter of objection has
been received in relation to the tpo
stating that the tree is leaning causing
driveway cracks and drainage issues the
question of whether or not to confirm
the tpo has been brought before members
however it is the office of
recommendation on the basis of the
immunity value of the tree and the lack
of agricultural justification
demonstrating that the tree is the cause
of the previously mentioned issues or
that there are no other alternative
solutions other than its removal to fix
the problems the tpa should be confirmed
thank you chairman
thank you right we do have a public
speaker on this one we have an objection
who is mrs pauline button
hello welcome um please come forward
make yourself comfortable
um you can spread yourself around if you
like
okay so i said make yourself comfortable
please use the microphone you have two
minutes precisely and i'm always very
precise and we start the clock when you
begin
okay good evening thank you for allowing
me to speak i'm objecting to the tpo
order 421 i reside at 37 fish street
the tree is causing damage to my
property as the roots are lifting my
driveway i cannot carry out any remedial
works to my driveway until the tree has
been removed
the tree may also be the cause of the
drain being blocked at the front of
number 39 which is causing flooding to
my driveway when we get heavy rainfall
essex highways are aware of the problem
and are looking into the calls also
saying that it could be because of the
roots of the tree
i also have several cables running
through the tree which could be pulled
down in high winds again i cannot carry
out any preventative work regarding the
flooding to my driveway due to the tree
being in position
i've been advised by a tree surgeon
arbor elite that the tree is in fact
dying and has several roots already dead
the tree is leaning toward the road and
i've been advised that this that should
this fall it will significantly damage
my property number 39
and due to the height of the tree may
even damage properties on the other side
of the road and more importantly could
seriously injure or kill someone if this
should happen it is also not a protected
tree
i also note that my property previously
had permission to fill two cypress trees
reference tca
mal0501206 and tcapn0500126
due to the size they had grown
and also one silver birch tca
mal1400795 as the roots of the tree were
damaging a neighbor's drain
i see no difference in what i am
proposing i'm trying to protect my
property and surrounding areas from
further damage
the aesthetics of the road are far less
important than damage to the property
and life
given that several trees on a plotting
fish street have already been felled as
planning permission is being sought i
urge you to reconsider the tpo and allow
me to fill the tree thank you
thank you
i'm perfectly tired
right up the council
i'll see you
soon thank you can we go back to the
photograph the street view photographs
please
thank you i mean i think we can all see
that it is a prominent feature on fish
street
um
i don't think anybody could deny that
even even in its uh
winter condition now can we go back to
the photos of the drive
now
unless i'm very much mistaken
those are fairly new drive surfaces that
have been put there certainly since the
tree
uh has been there
and i'm afraid i
i cannot see any reason why
uh
this tree should be felled i think you
know it's been there a darn sight longer
than the drives and probably the houses
as well
and i have a similar tribe a sycamore in
my back garden that also had a tpo on it
um
and
it was it's certainly a lot bigger than
that
but i'm afraid i cannot see the
justification the tree's been inspected
it's been graded
uh and it
merits uh the protection that has been
put on it and i would support this uh
tpl i'm afraid
councilman
oh too many likes thank you
no you're fine
thank you
anybody else
oh i actually spotted councillor white
first yeah but my
my only concern is that this really
isn't a suitable place for a tree it's
already as wide as the um
between the two garages and it's only
going to grow so i do have some
reservations about it um although i
can't see any logical reason to refuse
it normally i'm against all tpos um
but um but i can't quite see
a way around it in light of there not
being an up-to-date albacore alberta
cultural report i i do suspect there
might be problems with the routes
because of um the posts and the
driveways which we can't remove because
they're already there and i just think
it's a pity that the applicant didn't
send us these before now because we
can't take them into account if we
haven't already seen them so
i can't actually find a reason to not
confirm it whereas normally i would
cursor keys
oh thank you
um it says the tree's lean but if i look
at that bottom right picture
i would take it that fence post is
fairly straight
and i can't see the fence post either
side of that so once i said the tree's
not leaning that much and i do have
sympathy with them with the drive but as
councillor darum said there's been no
damn sight longer than
the houses and
yes the roots probably are causing
problems i think we can all
sum that because they say what's up
first he's downstairs on
the tree so just but now i yeah i can't
see a problem with it
i think i will second if counselor down
was putting up
just to make another point in in 5.5 of
the officer's report um
it does stay sort of i'm trying to you
know kind of truncating paraphrasing um
after establishing the value of the tree
and that's clearly seen in in the
photographs and i think again as
councillor durham pointed out i mean you
know it's a deciduous tree and we're
seeing it at its barest and you can
still see the substantial
um uh size of its of it of of his
obvious tree the branches etc you can
imagine when it's in the summer time and
it's in its you know full glory
um
the purpose of it you know there may
well be issues in some future we don't
know i mean maybe in 10 years time or
something we just don't know but part of
the purpose of of of of the tpo is that
if it ever came to a position where for
some reason it had to be removed we
could secure a replacement
because the character of the area has
been established by that substantial
tree obviously also in this historical
context and that's important to consider
as well so i just wanted to sort of make
that point
thank you thank
you for that
it's regularly every two to three years
it gets a good haircut
and then comes back and that keeps it
under control because they are a big
tree but that is one of the benefits of
they are actually very attractive tree
and i think as we see the street thing
will be
much the worse if it's disappeared
okay thank you well the recommendation
isn't like a normal planning one it's
to confirm
um we've had a proposal
the officer's recommendation those in
favor
anyone against
miss whiteham stalin
yeah that's
okay so that tpo is confirmed
um it doesn't mean no work can happen it
just means it can't be done really
nearly and if it is taken down it has to
be replaced
so now we have another tpo which is
pearly
um
there is no one to speak on this as it
happens so if we can have the report
please mr turner
thank you chairman
said this is um another report seeking
confirmation of a tree preservation
order this one relates to an oak tree to
the southeast of primrose hal green road
in purley
again we have the location of the tree
shown in platform
aerial view
is the closer view and just gives you
some context of the tree in relation to
the adjacent dwelling
views of the tree looking towards the
north
so i'm close to normally views
views looking east and into the immunity
space it serves primrose
and then this is the glimpses that are
available looking south from the highway
the council were made aware that the oak
tree was at risk of being failed and so
undertook tempo assessments to determine
whether the tree was worthy of a tpo
the tree scored 15 out of 25 which meant
it warranted a tree preservation order
this was served on the 13th of october
an unresolved rejection objection has
been received in relation to the tpo
stating that the tree is causing
subsidence at the neighbouring dwelling
therefore the question of whether or not
to confirm the cpo has been brought
before members
its officers recommendation that the tpo
should be confirmed as no agricultural
evidence has been submitted to implicate
the tree in the subsidence issues nor
has it been demonstrated that there are
no other solutions available to mitigate
the issues other than to fill the tree
and furthermore the tree is considered
to be a significant meaning meaning
value to wherever your tpo i think as
shown in the photographs thank you
chairman
thank you um
i actually spotted council durham first
i'm doing this
benefit than the previous tree and
i can't see
any reason why
that particular tree if it's been
assessed and it's not under some alleged
subsidence isn't attributed to that tree
i can't see any justification for
allowing it to be removed um
so i would totally support you know
we're meant to be a green council
chairman and every meeting we go to
we're asked to confirm our green
credentials
and cutting down specimen oak trees like
that i think would be
um
rather hypocritical so i again support
this tpo
okay
thanks thank you madam sherman um
where is the um house
that's got the subsidence in relation to
the oak tree excuse me
as a from reading the letters i thought
it was right next door and so i'm a bit
surprised that i can't see a house
around it
there is on the plan it's there but it's
not that close is it doesn't look the
same on the planet
yes
to be fair it is far enough away um
that that doesn't bother me so much and
it at least it is a nice although i
really don't like tpos in general um i
don't have such a problem with that one
um i thought it was closer when i read
the um less from the agents i thought it
was right next door but it isn't as
close as i thought
the thing is and i'll say it so that mr
johnson doesn't have to is it's not so
much that that tree is there forever
it's the fact that if we can control
what happens next
so it could always be replaced and if
there's no tpo it can just be tanked
down and that's the end of that
i think that's pretty much it yeah
it always upsets me when applicants
apply to do work and then we put a tpo
on whereas if they've just done the work
and it didn't have a tpo they could have
done it but i have so i don't actually
have a problem with it that is true but
that's what yes yeah but i don't yeah
it's it's the way we kind of do it just
seems a bit unfair um
tpos on everything in the district
before we even started and you can't do
it without some justification yeah am i
right there that's what i've always been
yeah i mean there has to be a risk
i mean you know these are cases where
in
a number of situations there's there's a
dispute yeah
um
one gets to realize the other ones have
cut it down and they get in contact with
the council
and and we act on that basis i mean that
happens ever so
ever so often actually especially behind
the scenes
um
and what i would just sort of point out
on this one as well that's seven point
one point one under the two objections
and and i would say
you know i i read the
sort of what's behind the report that
comes to members
there are um opportunities for
redressing
some of the issues
as as stated even by the
object um
it's
the obviously the impression that i get
is that's not what the cause of acting
they want to pursue yeah so if we look
at where it says um the sort of third
section down under objection comment uh
if a root barrier is introduced or they
work around regular maintenance the tree
will be required to keep it to a size
that prevents further damage to our
property
but i think i think as you said council
durham i mean you know maintenance is
very much
okay well thank you we have a proposal
on the table which is to accept the
officer's recommendation which simply
confirms the tpo 521 without any
modifications i got the impression
council and morning might second that
those in favor
thank you anyone against
council white of staining
council might abstain okay
um so thank you that officer
recommendation is confirmed
i suspect they just don't like
collecting the leaves because mine makes
a huge amount of leaves
last night
so remember there's any other item
success the chairman decides are urgent
you'll be very pleased to hear there are
none
so with thanks to you members for your
contributions to the officers for their
contributions to
multitude and anyone who's listening
i close the meeting at 20 past eight